biggest reason i push kids to do what  they want versus what their parents want  when you're 60 and they're 80 and you  lived your life based on what they  wanted  and now you resent them it gets real  ugly real fast  i would rather you have the pain for the  next five or six years of fighting  and then have one of two things happen  which i think both are amazing  number one you were right you were right  and you are an amazing fashion designer  not an engineer  and you built a real company and your  parents are gonna be very very  proud or you were wrong you suck at  fashion design  nobody liked it but at least for  yourself you never have to live the rest  of your life  asking yourself what if you win both  ways  regret is scary resentment  is very scary